thing is the notation they're either
going to show you something like this F
of G of X or G of f of X or instead of
writing it this way they'll write F of G
so they're gonna put a little circle
right there or G of F okay so different
from multiplication this is actually
means composition of functions so I'll
give you a couple examples like say for
example f of X equals 2x minus 1 and say
that G of X equals let's just say it's x
squared ok so say for example we wanted
to find out what is f of G of 3 okay
just like you do the order of operations
you start from the inside and you work
your way out so for example we would go
to the G function we would put 3 in for
X on the right so you can see that 3
squared is 9 so now we have F of 9 and
now whatever's here in parentheses
that's our input that goes in for X on
the right and we get 2 times 9 minus 1
which is 17 so the result of doing one
function and that output becomes the new
input in the next function that's
composition of functions now I'll just
show you let's say we did this in
Reverse just so that you can see that
you don't get the same answer
necessarily so if we do G of F of 3
again here we're putting 3 in for X in
the F function so that's going to be 2
times 3 which is 6 minus 1 is 5
okay now we're calculating what is G of
5 okay so 5 is our input that goes in
for X on the right that's 5 squared
which is 25 and you can see those are
not the same so the idea is you do one
function and then another function and
sometimes you can do three four or five
of these compositions okay now here I
used a specific number like 3 okay or 5
or like 9 whatever but what we're going
to do now is we're going to just do it
in a generic sense so say for example we
wanted to do just F of G of X like this
so G of X actually equals x squared so
now what I have is f of x squared
whatever is in the parentheses that's
the input that goes in place okay of X
on the right side of the equation so you
can see this is going to be 2 times x
squared minus 1 and if you simplify you
can just write it like that okay if we
do it the other way let's say we want to
do G of f of X now we can see that
two X minus one oops two X minus one is
our input into our G function so
whatever is here goes in for X on the
right so you can see that's going to be
2 X minus 1 the quantity squared and you
can foil that out or you could leave it
like that okay so do you understand the
idea basically about how compositions of
functions work ok so now a more
challenging example that had a couple
students asking about recently our find
f of X and G of X such that H of X okay
which is which are these two functions
here equal F of G of X so the two
functions compose together so what we're
doing is we're actually coming up with
our own two functions that when you
compose them you end up with this result
here H of X and there's more than one
answer so realize that so for example
one option we could do here for F of G
of X is we could say that G of x equals
the inner part of this square root so we
could say this is 2x minus 3 and f of X
okay which is one that we do second is
the outer part which is just the square
root so you can see here what we're
doing when we do F of G of X is we're
taking G of X okay which is 2x minus 3
and we're putting it in to our F
function in place of X so that becomes
square root of 2x minus 3 and that's
what we have there now there's more than
one answer like I said another option
would be to go like this you could say
hmm G of x equals 2x so now we're just
using this part here and f of x equals
the square root of x minus 3 so now what
we have is when you put the G of X
function right into the F function we're
putting 2x in place of X and we're
getting this H of X function are you
with me so far so these are a little bit
more challenging let's look at another
example so here they give us the result
of composing F of G of X right and so
here what we'll do is you need the
easiest way to do it is to think about G
of X just like it's the inner quantity
here look for the innermost quantity on
this function so we could say that let's
say G of x equals this inner quantity
here 9 X minus 7 and f of X equals 1
over 3 times the quantity X square
so now you can see you're putting nine X
minus seven in place of X when you do
this composition of functions now that's
not the only way to do it another option
would be here there's a lot of options
here but let's just do one more G of X
you could just say equals 9x for example
okay so now we're just working with this
piece right here and f of X equals 1
over 3 times X minus 7 the quantity
squared so now we're putting 9x in place
of X when we do that composition so
again these are a little bit more
challenging I'll have a link to a video
that I did just talking about some of
the simpler just basic straightforward
composition of functions so you can
check out that video if you want to
learn more subscribe to the channel
check out some more videos on Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel and I
look forward to seeing you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon